well i think the attacks that russia is
carrying out on civilian targets clearly
deliberately are just sickening and
appalling we saw the attack just there
on a shopping center yesterday but it's
not a one-off we've seen them over the
last three months attacking
children's hospitals we've seen them
attacking maternity wings we've seen
them
bombing flats there is apparently no end
to the barbarity of putin's frankly
criminal regime in the way that they're
not only invading a free sovereign
country
but apparently intentionally
deliberately
killing and targeting civilians as well
i think it was good we saw at the g7
just a couple of days ago
those g7 leaders including
president macron following his uh
meeting with our prime minister stating
their resolve to stay with ukraine i
think it's essential we stay with
ukraine uh throughout this uh invasion
we do everything we can to support them
the uk has provided 1.3 billion pounds
worth of support
so far we've provided uh 5 000 anti-tank
missiles we've provided anti-aircraft
missiles we've provided anti-ship
missiles
uh we've provided humanitarian aid we're
offering to train 10 000 ukrainian
troops every 120 days so we need we in
the west not just the uk but the entire
west
need to do everything we can everything
to support ukraine militarily in this at
dark hour which they which they face are
we prepared to send troops to ukraine
no we said we're not going to do that
because we are worried about escalation
and in fact if you talk to the ukrainian
government
their issue isn't troops they have a lot
of volunteers uh young men and women who
are volunteering to defend their
homeland as i hope people here but if
faced with a similar threat what they
need is equipment and that is what we're
pouring in as quickly as we can i would
just say to other governments around the
world
you know joint join us in doing that but
do it quickly there is a sense of
urgency here
we need to support ukraine not in a
month's time or two months time we need
to support them today so time is
critical
is it an act of terrorism what we saw
yesterday
uh i would yes i would go that far and
say that it is because it is
intentionally targeting civilians there
is no military necessities are bombing a
shopping center just as there was no
military necessity to bombing a
maternity hospital which we saw um all
that theater in uh maripo we saw them
bombing that theater where
civilians were taking shelter it was
clearly marked as containing civilians
so i mean this is not a one-off act it's
part of a consistent pattern of
atrocities being committed by the
russian government
are we ready to go to war with russia
we're going to hear from the head of the
army the new head of the army later on
today describing this as our 1937 moment
well i think that refers to the fact we
need to do everything we can to support
ukraine we don't want to see an
escalation into a wider conflict i think
russia would be literally insane
to attempt to do that because nato
is a far larger and a far stronger blog
we've seen the russians have been you
know unable to make significant uh
progress in ukraine right they tried to
take care of them they were unable to do
so so russia would be
sort of mad to try and take on nato we
don't think they'll do that we don't
think they should do that we certainly
don't want to see that happen we think
we can we are prepared for it we are
prepared for anything but we think we
can support the ukrainian government
with the current strategy which is to
give them uh the weapons they need to
liberate their own territory
are we prepared for it though because
the impression that we're getting is
that we have something like 40 000 um
war ready troops at the moment that is
going to be significantly increased not
just in the uk um to 300 000. but that's
going to take time that's right well
there's obviously a nato summit um going
on and i think the commitment of nato
nations to protecting
the territorial integrity of nato
countries particularly on that eastern
flank the flank that faces russia is
clearly more important today than it
ever has been before and i think the
uplifting troops you just mentioned the
um the troops who are ready to be
deployed
is a signal of the uh serious commitment
that nato collectively has to defending
all of nato's member states including
those states on the eastern flank what
we're going to do about putin if this is
an act of terror then that makes him the
arch terrorist we could never ever do
business with him again
well i think uh the the russian
regime putin's regime is uh irreversibly
tarnished and tarnished is too weak a
word by the way
what they've done we're only just
disgraced in in international in
international eyes
and
i think it is difficult to see how
uh we can deal with them ordinarily
again certainly so long as they remain
in occupation of a of a free democratic
sovereign country um i believe that ben
wallace is going to write to rishi sunak
and say that we need to
increase the defending defense spending
target to two and a half percent of gdp
it's presently at two percent um is that
something that you're aware of is that
something that you would support well
then spending as a proportion of gdp is
currently just over two percent which is
the nato uh guideline many nato
countries sadly um don't spend the two
percent and i think one of the things
one of the things we would one of the
things i'm going to come into that one
of the things we would urge all our nato
allies to do is to meet that two percent
at least
you know clearly uh we have had a good
defense settlement uh just recently uh
obviously ministers uh secretaries of
state across government make
representations to the prime minister
and the chancellor around their own
budget and they'll get properly
considered at the time of a spending
review but this is a government that is
committed to our armed forces that's why
we're above that two percent level we're
about to cut out from eighty or thousand
to seventy odd thousand well i mean you
look at you look at the way well look at
the way that uh modern warfare is
conducted and make sure that the money
is being spent most effectively i made
the point already in new york relation
to ukraine that what they've said is
most important are the other systems the
weapon systems that are needed to fight
as well as trump
minister but you know we're again going
to hear from the head of the armed
services who will tell us that um cyber
security doesn't get you across the
river
that's right i mean it's true the truth
is you need both you need the cyber
security measures you need the advanced
uh weapon systems um the drone the
impact of drones in the ukraine conflict
has been i think far greater than anyone
would have anticipated and you need
boots on the ground the truth is in a
modern theater you need all of those
things okay talk to me about um indie
ref 2. um nicholas sturgeon says it's
going to go ahead whatever the british
government thinks
well that isn't how the law works uh
referendum and constitutional matters
are reserved we had a referendum in 2014
the scottish people delivered their
verdict by a fairly clear 10-point
margin nicholas sturgeon at the time and
her then mentor alex salmond said very
clearly to the scottish people this was
going to be a once in a generation
referendum it was only a few years ago
that's not once in a generation i think
nicola sturgeon should respect the will
of the scottish people
that was expressed so clearly in that
referendum
and not not once in a generation um and
um i respect the will of the people in
that referendum and focus on the key
issues that matter there was an opinion
poll published by yougov just a few
weeks ago
showing that only 28 of scottish people
wanted a referendum this year or next
the vast majority did not and in fact
when they were asked to rank the
important issues facing scotland another
independence referendum
was rated seventh backed by only
mentioned only by 16 percent i mean if
that's the case if you think that the
scottish people are not up for it let
them have the referendum well they're
not they're not having a referendum
right 28 of people only 28 of people
said they wanted a referendum this year
or next there are more important issues
facing the country
and facing scotland issues to do with
the economy in scotland top issues with
the economy health and education those
are the issues frankly that both the uk
government and actually the scottish
government because health and education
are completely devolved to the scottish
government they should be focusing on
those issues you know scotland has the
highest rate of uh drug-related deaths
in europe those are the things nicholas
sturgeon should be focusing on not
re-running
a referendum that we had just a few
years ago and which she told us was a
once-in-a-generation referendum sure to
respect the will of the scottish people
sounds like you're telling her how to do
her job
i'm telling her just to um respect the
result of a democratic referendum just
as you know we respected we respected
the result of the brexit referendum you
know democracy only works if you respect
the result of the vote you have okay um
you've got quite a lot on your plate as
far as the uk government is concerned um
strikes by rail workers airport workers
postal workers looking at it teachers
are looking at it barristers are on
strike how are you going to fend off
this summer of discontent
well i mean clearly this has been
largely triggered by the inflation
figures those those are global figures
the oecd inflation average is almost
exactly the same as the uk average
couple of points first of all it's
important that we take action
to help people get through this um what
i hope is a short-term situation so
we've got this 37 billion pound package
targeted at people on lower incomes
that's the 400 pound
fuel rebate it's 150 pounds off council
tax it's the 650 pounds they know all
that people on
credit is the five p or fuel duty so
we're doing a lot to help people get
through this crisis not enough says
well particularly people on lower
incomes look um
we're expecting this to be a transitory
phenomenon it's driven by things like
the ukraine crisis like the covid
situation in china and the supply chain
issues those kind of things so we're
expecting this to be something which is
uh transitory if we have a series of
across the board pay increases for
everybody
then what's going to happen is that
we'll just feed even more inflation i
mean imagine hypothetically we say
tomorrow everybody in the whole economy
gets a 9 pay rise right which is
essentially what these strikes are
asking for if we did that all that would
happen is prices would then jump up by
another 9 the day afterwards because
companies would have to raise prices in
order to
pay their payloads wages taxes would
have to go up to fund it and it's to the
extent there was excess money floating
around in the system that would drive
inflation so an across-the-board pay
increase tomorrow is for everybody is
not how you beat inflation we sort of
tried that in the 1970s and you just get
into a deathly spiral of wage increases
driving more inflation it's like a dog
chasing its tail we need to
help the people that he's helping which
we're doing with the 37 billion pounds
get through this what i hope is a
temporary situation put in place the
measures um to tame inflation in the
longer term which is partly monetary
measures so interest rates and
quantitative easing is partly reform to
our economy to make it more efficient
and my job as technology minister covers
that if we can adopt
technology more widely to our economy
then our economy gets more efficient and
that tends to bring prices down so there
are no there are no sort of easy fixes
to inflation but one thing we should not
be doing is having just universal nine
percent pay increases because that will
make inflation worse and it will make it
permanent and that is bad for everybody
there you're gonna get me in trouble if
you don't stop talking so we're gonna
have to leave it there thank you very
much indeed for joining us